two bedroom two bathrooms 1,300 square
feet waterfront luxury apartment with a
dope-ass view great amenities like a
swimming pool I'll never use and also
private marinas but no one can afford a
boat because the rent is too damn high
so welcome to my crib that a shelf to
her roommates what's poppin welcome to
my new and improved apartment because
I'm hella rich now that YouTube money
dude I can't give you a ride I don't
have a car dude I spent all my money on
this apartment I can afford a car mmm
anyways the first part of the tour is
the kitchen first is this super cool
Japanese knives like this amazing what I
show you this one's mine but we also
have a super cool marble island which is
really really nice and then we have this
super cool rice cooker that actually
uses machine learning technology to cook
the rice perfectly and it's actually
true I'm not joking it's like fuzzy
logic you should search it up
unfortunately my roommates are not home
so we have like no groceries so there's
probably gonna be empty oh my god what
blue apron oh it's not empty at all this
video is sponsored by a blue apron thank
you so much blue apron for sponsoring
this video so now I can pay my boy Matt
Cho so don't forget the first 50 people
to sign up will get $50 off their first
two weeks with blue apron just click on
a description down below oh hey Matt can
you cook for me
while matt is cooking the food let me
tell you a little bit about our sponsor
so blue apron that allows you to create
delicious chef design recipes at home so
it's super convenient perfect to impress
a hot date and the thing I like the most
about it
price start as low as 749 per serving
which is way cheaper than eating out
which is perfect for people who are
cheap like me also if you have
commitment issues
like me it's okay because you can skip
or cancel the service at any time so if
you're interested please click the link
in the description box and get $50 off
your first two weeks it really helps
support blue apron and also my channel
so yeah
Bon Appetit all right back to the
apartment tour now next let's check out
the dining area Wow
oh my god Matt Joe thank you for leaving
all your junk on my dining table but
yeah when Matt Joe isn't here it's like
a beautiful dining table and there's a
chess set and we usually eat here but oh
well and then let's go to the living
room my favorite thing about my living
room is the projector because you can
Netflix and chill or even better
my youtube channel hey let's pop in so
then the next thing is oh yeah let's
check this off you know if you're
watching TV you could plug your phone
and charge your iPhones and if you're an
Android user what is too bad but doesn't
matter cuz your battery priority isn't
trash all right and then if you go over
to this couch you could see my beautiful
corgis damn but you know what's cuter my
little Groot assistant right here so
Groot is actually my lighting assistant
which is pretty cool because I could
tell him to turn on the lights and he
will check this out
Groot turn on the light Groot turn off
the light Groot turn off the light ok um
sometimes group can be a little bit
stubborn but I love them alright so next
let's check out the coffee table now
what does a coffee table need
a coffee book so this is twice really
cute love my love my kpop stuff alright
and that's it for the living room let's
go to my room alright and to make sure
that people know that's my bedroom we
got this big big mochi and also we got
my roommate greeting people coming in
and also my dope as painting alright
let's go to my room come on in come on
in so welcome to my bedroom where all
the magic happens
and by magic I mean the magic of editing
but yeah anyways if you look over here
you're gonna see a painting of a girl
which is probably the closest thing I'll
ever get to having a girl my bedroom
anyways I do like paintings so which is
why I have three paintings over here
this is abstract art it's pretty hard to
comprehend the meaning of this so I'm
not even gonna bother trying to explain
to you guys alright so here is my
station my battle station where I edit
all my videos I've got my microphone and
my tissue box Stan got my lg monitor got
my laptop and oh my god you got a kiwi
bird so cute and then we also have the
Ducks here pretty cute
here we have my personal laptop that I
used to watch my favorite videos on read
to I mean on YouTube read and then here
is a lot of guerrilla pods for filming
and stuff like that on my hard drive oh
wow
here I got four iPhones you know one for
each girl not just testing devices but
whatever and then finally my beautiful
bed I do miss my bunk bed you know I
mean you guys complained about my bunk
bed saying like oh my god why you selves
a bunk man or an adult or here you go I
got a queen-size bed now and guess what
it's actually such a waste of space
because I literally sleep like this so
there's so much space time wasting oh my
god and it's not like I have a
girlfriend so if you're a girl I'm
watching this video don't forget to sign
to my dns call my kidding man I don't
have any girl viewership anyways let's
go to the bathroom and onto the bathroom
now let's see what I have here I have
some cotton pads q-tips
I got toothbrush and got a makeup
remover for my non-existent girlfriend
oh [ __ ] and then also I got these little
cloth they're super expensive but I
thought there were something else
anyways and then the great thing about
this bathroom is that you can watch your
videos wow you get ready and also the
cool thing about this surface book is
that you can actually detach it look at
this oh my god I [ __ ] hate surface
books man they always break okay so I
can't detach it right now because the
surface books suck oh my god oh my god
okay it's working now but you can detach
it and watch your favorite videos while
you take a shower you know so you could
be entertained and then it's also
attached to this what is the UE boom
speaker so you can make it real loud are
you kidding
[Music]
alright in case you're wondering why I
bought a surface book I did not buy a
surface book okay I got the surface book
for free when I did an internship at
Microsoft and the reason why they gave
it out for free is because they know
that these piece of hardware would
become irrelevant
just like my youtube channel but anyways
so ok [ __ ] this let's put it back and
this is the worst tour ever
okay ah
anyways let's talk about this mirror a
lot of people love this mirror because
it's perfect for selfies but I think
it's a little bit too bright because it
covers all my flaws my complexion and
also my deep insecurities that repress
20 years ago but it also makes my abs
look good so I guess that's fine but
yeah let's wrap up the tour so come on
now all right thank you so much for
checking out the tour with me now if you
liked this video don't forget to like
and subscribe so yeah I hope you enjoyed
the tour
and have a great day peace
can you fill me a little bit again okay
peace that's about it
okay you almost say it's not for me
George thank you so so much